rotherham is a typical northern
industrial town but now it's also known
as the most shameful town in Britain
it's where hundreds of children and
teenagers were groomed and sexually
abused Jessica was one of them 16 years
ago the now 29 year old was basically
still a child when she met a man who
turned out to belong to a gang whose
members were largely of Pakistani origin
it was 24 it was smartly dressed and and
I was quite in awe of him and it was
kind it was funny gentle admit my life
you'd pay me compliments he first of all
came into my world and he found out
everything there was to know about me
what music alight and you know my
friends were my family were what school
I went to what my interests were my
hobbies Jessica never suspected that
this kind and friendly man 10 years
older than she was was a drug dealer and
child molester she gave everything up
for him isolating herself from her
friends and family only gradually did he
start to reveal his true violent nature
Jessica overwhelmed and helpless went
along with everything used to be I was
anally raped and at that age I didn't
even know it was physically possible to
do that to someone shame kept her from
confiding in anyone even her sister but
her parents who had briefly met the man
since their daughter was suffering
Jessica's father would spend evening
searching the pubs and hotels of the
city trying to find his daughter who
sometimes disappeared for days at a time
her family was gravely concerned and
turned to police early on
yeah they used to threaten to arrest me
Father for wasting police time when he
used to go down to report it and
threatened to remove me dad from the
police station that was the experience
of many families in Rotherham whose
children fell into the grip of the
Pakistani gangs of child molesters
rumors were rife about the gangs
criminal dealings they victimize some
1,400 children and teenagers in
Rotherham but neighbors remained silent
and for years the police covered up for
the perpetrators Jane senior was part of
an independent youth project helping
victims of sexual violence she was one
of those responsible for bringing the
scandal to light what we also had is and
a lot of comments about in a race issue
and not wanting to upset our Muslim
communities what we've actually done
these cause more damage to those
communities than if we'd have actually
gone into them communities ten years ago
and said this is happening can we work
together nearly 200 police officers in
Rotherham are under investigation but
much remains unclear there's a great
deal of shame over the matter and
questions about the scandal are
unwelcome not just within the Muslim
community all right now everybody just
we've got a bus to catch windows finish
work
so we're going to go all right
I can talk I'll talk about exciting
the police commissioner has been failed
to do his job a lot of people in the
council building has failed to do their
jobs and at the minute we have
government always in our Tony basically
and while solving things which is good
and we're hopefully elwro it will get
done soon the what the media exactly
well yet it makes it too big I think
Jessica was finally able to have her
story hurt and with the help of a victim
support organization she filed charges
against her abuser arshid Hussein he's
been sentenced to 35 years in prison in
one of the first trials against the
rather on gangs Jessica's mother did not
live to see the sentencing her family
believes she died of grief the trial
ended just two months ago and jessica
hasn't yet recovered from her
experiences the best thing for her is to
be with people she trusts I want to
focus on my health and spending time
with family and the investigations
ticket so much in my life it went over
two and a half years Jessica intends to
continue helping to uncover the child
sex abuse scandal she encourages other
women to file charges against their
abusers but that activism has also made
her a target of threats in rotherham